I'm Franklin hippo I'm a nuclear
physicist I've been at Princeton since
1974 working on nuclear weapons issues
and I see this as a great opportunity
with the election of President Trump and
this the responsive citizen uprising
that this may be an opportunity to move
our agenda forward on nuclear
disarmament I was part of the last wave
in the early 1980s when we rose against
the early Reagan administration and
helped in the Cold War and the nuclear
arms race and reduced the number nuclear
weapons we have but there's still too
many your posture too dangerously launch
on warning he would still have one man
who can order there use all these issues
have to be dealt with and I welcome I
would I would welcome that the citizen
uprising the president rumpus has
stimulated to develop a nuclear
dimension as well to try to move our
nuclear agenda forward toward nuclear
nuclear disarmament well science is just
a bunch of tools and there's nothing
magic about science it just happens I'm
enjoying mathematics I enjoy calculating
things so I make a living doing science
I don't regard that as a big any
particular qualification to be wise but
it is the most important thing about
science as far as the public is
concerned is it is a real international
activity we really do operate with our
friends all over the world so we have
very good connections with countries
which normally regarded as enemies
that's why we are useful I would say for
this kind of situation you want to talk
about nuclear weapons not just with your
friends you want to talk with your
enemies scientists are the best people
to do that because they happen to know
that enemies already my name is Joseph
Taylor and I'm professor of physics
emeritus at Princeton University I
happen to have been awarded the Nobel
Prize in Physics in 1993 my own work is
in astrophysics has to do with the
discovery of pulsars and their
interaction particularly in a binary
pulsar system that gave us confidence
that gravitational radiation as
predicted by Einstein's relativity
theory actually exists I've had a
wonderful life in in science and in
physics I believe that science is
extraordinarily important in today's
world important to the development of
technologies which have made life more
happy and in generally more prosperous I
think it's extremely important to the
nation and to other nations that
scientific knowledge inform public
policy and that's the primary reason
that I'm here at this session today I
simply want to lend my support to the
efforts that are being made to limit the
distribution of nuclear weapons to limit
their number to in fact stigmatize them
to the effect that they will be seen as
negative contributions to to the
stability of the world and the good for
for the citizens of the world I'm Alex
Plaza I work at Princeton University I
am trained as a physicist but I do arms
control and news I'm in for a living i I
support the ban treaty movement I think
there has not been much progress in
nuclear arms control and and
the NPT the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty is important but it hasn't really
delivered what I think international
community expects I believe now is a
time to move the agenda forward and and
and really you know make progress toward
nuclear disarmament I work with students
I teach students who were born in 1990
they have not seen much progress since
then since the end of the Cold War they
don't really understand what you know
others mean by a step-by-step approach
when since the mid-1990s we haven't
really seen much if anything so I think
the band movement is is kind of it's
very important and kind of changing this
this are making a difference in this
stalemate hi my name is Jonathan King
I'm a professor of molecular biology at
MIT I made my scientific living studying
organisms little things proteins the
building blocks of machinery that all
living things depend on I've always been
interested in how things get built how
it is good to know how a seed becomes a
plant how and had it becomes an embryo
in the 1970s most of the nations of the
world signed the treaty the biological
weapons convention strongest disarmament
treaty human history it banned the use
of human weapons banned the development
and the stockpiling and we really
thought we had put a genie back in the
bottle but then the early 1980s
President Reagan revived climbing the
Soviet Union was Needle empire and he
revived spending my tax dollars on
biological weapons he called the
biological defense program opening up
old laboratories and together with a few
colleagues we organized the National
Campaign a petition campaign of
biological scientists who pledged that
they would not use their skills and
talents to work on military issues in my
life
biology and we were able to get enough
publicity to pressure the key Committee
of the Senate John Glenn the astronaut
is that the chair of it to get them to
take the key step of fully ratifying the
biological weapons convention definitely
a step forward so we know these things
can happen nuclear weapons for anybody
who has any concern for them for living
things nuclear weapons which obliterate
incinerate every living thing plants
animals insects microorganisms worms
beetles in the blast zone in a way that
they won't recover problems for
thousands of years this is had no place
in human society at all of any kind and
so you know I'm here at the United
Nations with many many other scientists
hoping that the United Nations will
bring pressure to man to get rid of
these nuclear weapons forever and with
the earth of the scourge of this insane
weapons of mass destruction my name is
Xia Mian
I'm a physicist I work at Princeton
University in the program on science and
global security where I've been for 20
years and my training in physics
actually in the early 1980s overlapped
with the heightening of the Cold War
under President Reagan and that led to
many questions being asked of scientists
and physicists in particular
about nuclear weapons and the need for
the public in democracies to be able to
understand what their governments are
doing when it comes to the threat of use
of nuclear weapons and the possibility
that such weapons would actually be
catastrophic
for Humanity this was also the time that
Carl Sagan was introducing the world to
the ideas of nuclear winter and what
would happen if there was a large scale
nuclear war between the United States
and the Soviet Union
so I actually met Carl Sagan we
overlapped in several conferences
and this was a very important time for
scientists to think about their
responsibilities in democracies and if
you ask the question why scientists have
a special role in democracy then I think
the focus has to be the fact that
scientists as citizens have an
obligation to bring whatever skills and
insights they have and share it with the
rest of the citizens in their societies
and with humanity at large because we
have the privilege of being given the
time and the opportunity to devote to
understanding the way the world works
and we have an obligation to share the
understanding with everybody who's
possibly interested in that so that they
can make the best possible decisions
concerning themselves in the world they
live in and how that world is managed
and governed by those with power over it
and when it comes to nuclear weapons
this is an especially important
responsibility so I've been very
privileged all my life as a scientist to
be able to try and combine my training
in science and physics with the
responsibility of citizenship to try and
engage citizens and people everywhere in
the debate about what nuclear weapons
mean and how humanity can free itself
from the scourge of nuclear war
[Music]
[Music]